du spectacle sur la piste du vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour cette
quatrième édition du grand prix de
vélizy frédéric est venu avec son frère
et son fils pour regarder les champions
c'est la première fois que je venais au
vélodrome j'ai souvent eu l'occasion
souvent envie de venir mais jamais eu
l'occasion de devenir le vélodrome c'est
quelque chose de sympathique de nouveau
pour moi et c'est vrai que c'est
impressionnant voit cette trempe là on
se demande comment on peut tenir dessus
pour tenir sur la rampe les pistards se
prépare à l'effort
c'est le cas de guillaume sous terre
engagés sur la course par élimination
le principe tous les deux tours le
cycliste arrivé en dernier est éliminé
une épreuve remportée par guillaume je
suis content est-ce que toujours plaisir
de gagner surtout qu'il ya quand même du
niveau et je me suis bien fait mal aux
pattes donc la victoire au bout c'est
sympa scratch vitesse par équipes tempo
différentes disciplines du cyclisme sur
piste de la catégorie shauna seniors
masculines et féminines venant de
différentes régions
c'est un révélateur de jeunes talents
faut pas oublier que à la première
édition nous avions laurie berton
quentin lafargue nous avions benjamin
thomas morgan kneisky qui sont tous en
équipe de france et qui sont devenus
champions du monde lui est déjà champion
du monde catégorie junior de vitesse
individuelle à 18 ans reillanne elle a
rejoint le pôle france
il a participé à l'épreuve de keirin
huit tours dont 6 effectué derrière la
moto avant un sprint final remporté par
le jeune espoir
le pistard de vélizy yens dujarrier est
arrivé troisième dans le jeu
attentive à ce qui se passait derrière
j'ai tout de suite vu que derrière je
voulais pas trop prendre la tête je suis
pas je reste en tête et j'étais
vigilants derrière super content j'avais
j'ai tiré le bon le bon numéro jus dans
la roue du japon du monde j'ai juste
essayé de conserver sa roue je suis
resté dedans et avec le boîtier que
j'avais une amie j'ai réussi même à
pouvoir ré accélérer sur sur la dernière
ligne droite
deuxième manche de cette compétition au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le dimanche 26 novembre